nos troupes se déplacent dans des
conditions de combat extrêmement
violentes l'aveu de la vis ministre de
la Défense ukrainienne elle annonce que
l'armée avance très lentement notamment
en direction de barmouth et évoque des
succès partielles Gulliver crack bonjour
vous trouvez à zaporry Jah vous revenez
de la région de donet sur la ligne de
front qu'avez-vous constaté
alors j'ai été dans le sud de la région
de donuts pas du tout la même direction
que pakmouth mais du côté de Velika
nouveau Silka qui est près de du
Conflent avec la région de zaborija on
entend les bruits des tirs tout le temps
avalicanovacica plus fort que 15 km
derrière c'est 15 km derrière velica
nouveau Silka que je me suis arrêté un
certain temps pour discuter avec des
soldats beaucoup ne dévoilent aucune
information si ce n'est pour dire que le
moral est haut et que ça va et que ils
avancent selon le plan mais j'ai parlé à
un officier qui m'a expliqué qu'en fait
ce qu'il le faisait ce matin en tout cas
et hier c'était consolidé leur gain
consolider les quatre villages qui ont
été pris au sud de velikanovosilca donc
toujours dans la partie ouest de la
région de Donetsk que les Russes
essayaient de reprendre de
contre-attaquer si vous voulez les
Ukrainiens sont en train d'essayer de
consolider leur relativement modeste
quand visiblement il continue en tout
cas officiellement il continue de tenir
ces quatre villages là mais ils sont un
petit peu sous la pression mais si on
veut comparer avec la scène qu'il
pouvait y avoir à ces endroits un peu
derrière la ligne de front près de
batmouth au moment où les Russes étaient
encore en train de attaquer papoutes
qu'il y avait une pâte extrêmement
féroce là les soldats qu'on rencontrait
montrer des clercs signes de fatigue et
que il sortait vraiment d'une bataille à
très très difficile ça c'était pas du
tout l'ambiance ce matin dans la zone de
bellicano bossilka en tout cas plutôt
ils étaient tranquilles confiants ils
étaient aussi quelques peu critiques
envers une certaine partie de la
population locale qui estiment garder
tes points de vue prorus ce même
officier m'a dit un très très grand
nombre des Ukrainiens de l'Est qui
étaient pro à grande échelle à changer
d'avis et sont maintenant devenus des
patriotes Ukrainiens mais au grand
chagrin de cet officier pas tous mais il
a dit que la présence d'officiers de
soldats venus du crâne de l'Ouest avec
une bonne influence sur les populations
locales qui pour beaucoup d'entre eux
n'étaient jamais sortis de ces régions
de l'est de l'Ukraine ces régions
russophones où ils avaient beaucoup
regardé la propagande russe à la télé
qui disait que les Ukrainiens de l'Ouest
c'était des nazis etc et que petit à
petit ils arrivaient à gagner le soutien
de plus en plus de monde
en Gulliver donc la contre-offensive se
poursuit les frappes russes aussi
d'ailleurs il y a des civils qui ont de
nouveau été frappés ces dernières heures
ouais malheureusement ouais c'est ça il
y a trois morts dans une frappe sur un
centre commercial il y a eu je pense que
vous l'avez évoqué six morts contre
minibus a été frappé dans la région de
soumis et puis ce matin à cramator ce
qui est à Constantini car de grandes
villes de la partie de la région de
donuts qui est restée aux mains des
Ukrainiens il y a je pense deux morts à
crémator ce qui est un à Constantini
voilà pour les civils qui ont été tués
dans des frappes ces dernières heures
mais je pense qu'il convient toujours de
souligner que la très grande majorité
des morts dans cette guerre c'est bien
des soldats dont tous les villages et
les villes de
Ukraine en ce moment il y a de nouvelles
tombes dans les cimetières ce sont des
soldats tombés pour la patrie
merci beaucoup pour